[Music]
Jennifer Garner makes a rare appearance
with her son Samuel that's right the
actress stepped out with her 11 year old
on Sunday for the Lakers game against
the Golden State Warriors
check out the mother and son Duo all
smiles as they enjoy some quality time
together you have to find time for your
kids an eyewitness tells ET Jen and
Samuel were caught on the dance cam
jamming out and having a good time and
Samuel made the outing a moment to rep
both California teams wearing one Steph
Curry sneaker and another for LeBron
James
now this isn't the first time Samuel's
gotten the NBA VIP treatment the tween
joined his dad Ben Affleck last month at
the All-Star celebrity game in Utah all
right I'm here with my man and Ben won
some big dad points bringing Samuel's
Center Court to announce the starting
lineup this basketball influencer has
traveled all over the NBA creating
videos seen by hundreds of millions of
fans the little Cloud master and my
favorite YouTuber Jessica
Samuel's the youngest of Ben and
Jennifer Garner's kids they're also
parents to Serafina and violet my areas
of extra cheese is the kids not homework
and now that Ben's married to Jennifer
Lopez they are all adjusting to blended
family life the family doesn't have to
look like any particular model you what
it needs is like love adults that care
about you seems co-parenting between the
exes is going great
back in November A source told ET the
families are happier than ever and
everyone's getting along very well quote
they feel very unified let me do our
best we can go try our best
[Music]
thank you